hello thanks so much for having me here
you might not be able to tell from my
accent but as I was introduced I was
actually born and raised here so very
very honored to be here for the last day
as comfy you so how was lunch yeah I
thought it was pretty good too I was
choking it down because of Noah but it's
fine so so we're going to be talking
about a pretty exciting new API that you
might have accidentally discovered in
your browser
it's called webby or speed I'm going to
try and give you a gentle introduction
but after I proposed this talk and it
was accepted I realized a more
appropriate title was how do you send
the Sagan's
in a browser and so it's been an
interesting challenge of a sense so I'm
Suze Hinton you can follow me on github
and twitch and twitter as like no op cat
if you'd prefer to call me Newt cat
that's also fine I know some people were
really sad when they found out it wasn't
OOP
so I work on open source IOT libraries
in my spare time and then I'm I actually
get a salary from Microsoft during the
day and I do developer relations and I
mostly I'm concerned with IOT but
obviously that kind of goes hand-in-hand
with things like machine learning and
big data as well so I sort of do a
menagerie of things there to help smooth
over the experience when you're using
our tools so today's aim is for you to
see the browser and the web in a
different way I am bringing an agenda
that I've been banging on about for the
last I think four years now so some of
this might be familiar to some of you I
am back to talk about this and I also
want you to not be scared of hardware
and microcontrollers because this is
actually really exciting if you're a
friend and developer you now have the
opportunity to have an excuse to learn
more about this stuff and potentially
start writing hardware drivers in the
browser in JavaScript which is really
really fun so today we're gonna be
covering just a brief history of the web
and devices and how we've done things in
the past before this API what web USB is
and how that differs from you know our
previous attempts of this how to use web
u.s. speed I'm going to pray to the demo
gods ahead of time so that they'll sort
me out and be nice to me so if we are
lucky there'll be some demos and also
just to talk about the futures of
somewhere I think that it is going so
first a history of web USB which means
how do we use you know the browser to
create an interface to actual hardware
and we've had a varied amount of
approaches in the past I've been
successful some not so much
so my journey with web in USB started in
2007 I started with flash and a little
thing called flash communication server
and cert proxy so I'll explain briefly
how that worked let's say you have a
microcontroller let's say with an
Arduino because a lot of a lot of you
might already know what nods we know is
node we know is a really really really
great abstraction of hardware where you
have a microcontroller that you can very
easily plug things in and out of and you
can create really cool interactive
interactive experiences with it so the
Arduino I think came out around 2007
2008 in Australia I of course bought one
immediately and then I was like how do i
hook it up to the browser though because
i know HTML but I don't think that
Arduino talks hey - um OH
so you installed this program called sir
proxy which basically takes the serial
port connection and the data coming in
and out of the Arduino and it proxies it
to a TCP socket so you can treat that
stream as a TCP stream and then you
actually write your flash file and then
you essentially write some flash stuff
in flash communications over to connect
to that socket and to be able to write
to it and read from it from there you
can just whack the SWF file that you
export from flash onto a web page and
you don't that was quite a hack though
to get that going so here is just like
some of the code it's not super
important it's just for own history and
archaeological purposes you have your
ActionScript file where you're opening a
socket to a local host and with so proxy
when you start it up you give it a
config file essentially saying what port
you want to listen to what what TCP port
you actually want to open up the baud
rate of the device and the bits and the
parity and timeouts and all that kind of
stuff so it was okay but obviously we
know kind of where this journey went in
2008 in Australia we got the iPhone
I got the iPhone 3G it was awesome but
it didn't run flash and so after a few
years you know it flash definitely went
out of vogue because JavaScript started
being performant and there was some
pretty major like accessibility
performance and security issues with
flash as well so that kind of died for
me as a way of doing things because I
was just kind of feeling like I was
stuck in the past when I was doing it so
I believe it was in 2013 but maybe
Matias can correct me I would love if
someone could give me the actual date on
this but I think it was 2013 that a
technology called Chrome serial came to
Chrome browsers and so for a few years I
was actually playing with this it was
very very cool unfortunately I'll
explain what happened to it later okay
so we have the same scenario we have an
Arduino we have a browser and this time
we have Chrome serial which is basically
an API that you could access very
readily in the Chrome browser and you
use that in order to have like a way of
reading and writing from the device oops
then you actually have to have this
within a chrome app I'm not sure where
there was security issues or or what but
you absolutely had to use it in a chrome
app but it was still cool because if you
could write an extension or an app you
could actually start talking to an
Arduino in a browser and this actually
really had a huge impact on the
JavaScript community and especially
people who were trying to write Hardware
cross-platform like this is really where
the idea of cross-platform hardware
interfaces really started becoming a
thing that were very very compelling so
some of you might have heard of the chip
computer it was the famous nine dollar
computer that was on Kickstarter if you
don't know about it that's okay I worked
at Kickstarter at the time so that's
maybe why I know about it but it was
really really cool it was cheaper than
the Raspberry Pi at the time it was
before the Raspberry Pi zero and it was
essentially just Linux on a chip but it
was very very affordable and they did
something that I was super impressed
with they used a chrome app so that you
could update the firmware on the actual
chip you could update the operating
system on it which was awesome so you
downloaded this really cool thing called
the chip flasher and you plugged in your
chip and you just started up
dating it and I was like this this is
literally what I've wanted this whole
time for so many of my devices and for
so many interfaces that I've wanted to
make so I thought that that was super
progressive and you can see how friendly
that looks and how that's going to work
on any operating system that can run
Chrome shortly after that um I think
last year or maybe the year before do we
know actually came out with a chrome app
this is kind of the web version because
I don't have a nice high-res screenshot
of the chrome app but it is basically an
editor in the browser you can write your
sleek plus plus and it will compile it
and it will flash it on to your Arduino
all directly in the browser using Chrome
serial which is super magical and they
actually ended up using my library a VL
guard wiener to do that so I was like
really really excited to see that it was
kind of part of this future and it also
made me maintain it a little more
diligently than I normally would have
but um that was I was just like at the
peak of yes okay so this is a thing and
we're actually proving it so we're gonna
be able to keep Chrome serial right
unfortunately that didn't happen so
Chrome's serial was never like an
official web spam it was like very very
much in the chrome kind of ecosystem it
only worked in Chrome apps so you kind
of had to create this whole big thing so
if you wanted to have a website that you
could like interact with hardware you
kind of had to have this companion app
or companion extension that people would
have to install and then use your
website so it was a little bit awkward
and chrome apps with sunset for every
operating system except for Chrome OS in
2017 despite how many github please so
that was just kind of a shame but it
really kind of got me hooked on the idea
that you know browsers behave like
operating systems these days so there's
no reason why we can't actually do this
so what do we do these days well we
still sort of lean on our good friend
the WebSocket where our browser can be
the UI but we still need some kind of
back-end service that can actually do
the connection to the hardware because
the browser is very much locked out of
that so we've got out scenario as before
we can have something like a node.js
process for those of you who have done
node bots that would be something like
johnny-five that node.js process would
also have some kind of
websocket that it also sets up from the
back end and it might also be serving
that index.html at the same time as well
so it's actually doing a lot then you
have this WebSocket where your browser
can connect to it and you're just kind
of sending messages back and forth so if
the browser wants to do something with
the hardware you kind of come up with
your own WebSocket communication
protocol in order to do that it is still
not great having this kind of backend
coupling it's just not the experience
that it should be and this is what makes
people just go back to writing native
apps which brings its own challenges to
it as well so here is like an electron
app I made which is sort of like the
Holy Grail like electron allowed you to
combine those two processes together and
so I actually have the programmer right
here on stage that I use to program this
monogamist public radio so this is sort
of at the point where I sort of ended up
quitting hardware interfaces in the
browser because you know electron uses a
lot of CPU resources because it's a
whole chrome instance and it's also 110
megabytes so people had to download a
hundred and ten megabytes just to be
able to change the radio station on this
radio and it just felt really excessive
but it was cross-platform so it felt so
good but it's just it just wasn't right
so I sort of just got burnt out you know
it's been like what how many years has
it been almost 10 years since I first
started doing this and so I'm just like
and you you can actually still use the
Arduino editor if you don't have Chrome
OS what it does is it just has this
background app that runs in your taskbar
and it is using a WebSocket I was
debugging it last night it just kind of
uses that very same architecture so
that's another example of something that
uses that so now that we've had a look
at all the failures that we've had it
turned to get this stuff going what is
web USB itself because it's pretty
different to all the other purchas that
I showed so the web USB spec is actually
really cool I've been following it over
the last few years and it's definitely
gotten fleshed out the introduction part
is written in human text not spec text
so I promise I'm pulling a lot of this
from the spec because it is actually
really well written so the web usb API
provides a way to safely expose USB
device so
services to the web which is pretty cool
it provides an API familiar to
developers who have used existing native
USB libraries and exposes the device
interfaces defined by existing
specifications so this is really awesome
this particular point here because no
one's reinventing anything it you you
can expect to if you've ever done
low-level USB drivers before and again
it is possible to do it in JavaScript
that's sort of what I've been doing over
the last few years you will be
pleasantly surprised that a lot of your
stuff ports over really easily because
they haven't tried to reinvent the wheel
and come up with a new API you're you're
still doing things like control
transfers which I'll show you later and
claiming interfaces and it feels very
much like a regular low-level USB
experience so I think that was a really
important thing that they did it does
make it harder to get started but I
think that a lot of people are going to
be releasing abstractions to help out
with this pretty soon I'm hoping to find
the time to do so so it's important to
kind of tell you that Web USB is not the
same as serial so a lot of devices such
as the Arduino and other things they
have kind of a usb-to-serial like chip
in between that kind of tells the
machine that it's just a serial polit
that you can access so it's actually not
really a one-for-one replacement of
something like chrome serial or like
node serial port if you've used that
with no BOTS it's not quite the same you
can sort of get stuff working but you do
have to provide some shims and you sort
of pretending at serial but I'll show
you an example of that later on as well
in the demo but okay so if it's not
serial and things like that other than
the regular USB interface you're used to
why is it better well I really like that
they code out that it's kind of a safer
way to connect your browser to devices
so the first thing you get is if the
user actually has to initiate the
connection event themselves so someone
can't just go to your website and then
you immediately start polling all their
devices and trying to hack them it
actually just doesn't happen like that
so someone has to physically give
permission like clicking a box or having
some kind of keyboard event or some sort
of user initiated thing and even then it
pops up this really nice little modal
that says like you know this website
wants to connect to this device and so
you then have to physically click on
that device and click connect so there
are multi steps there similar to things
like your webcam and all sorts of other
permissions you've probably had such as
news websites warning sign to you
notifications and you always click the
block button it's very similar here you
can actually click cancel and you don't
actually have to take action which is
cool the other thing is there's this
really neat hook that they've put into
like you can put this in your device
descriptor on your on your actual
hardware itself when you plug it in you
can already suggest a website that
people can go to so as soon as I plug it
in chrome can helpfully pop up a little
notification saying hey I detected this
device like you probably want to go to
this website to start like interacting
with it and if you're curious fragile
systems is my new domain name I just
registered this week for all of my
really crappy duct-tape demos so if you
see any of my self with dark fragile
systems just be aware it's not perfect
code notes it's probably pretty terrible
so so yeah but you're probably thinking
like soos why why is why are you trying
to use the browser for everything like
you've got this hammer and you're trying
to like knock all the nails in and half
of them aren't even nails like what are
you doing and I honestly it's because
I've had to create how do I interfaces
before outside of the browser and
they're not fast to make they're it's
harder to make them cross-platform it's
hard to make them look good and a lot of
the a lot of the kind of native UI shims
for things like QT in that it's hard to
make it accessible out of the box or at
least I've struggled with that and so I
believe that hard way interfaces
shouldn't be left out of the experience
that we have as front-end developers
where our stuff is fast to make its
cross-platform out of the box it looks
good and it's accessible and so browsers
are a commonly installed application on
a lot of computers technically this
could probably be used offline if you
you know do your service workers right
and things like that that could be
really cool and yeah browser-based
interfaces like I said a rapidly
prototypes you can hot patch that easily
you can just deploy a change and the
user just Caesar
the next time they go to the website CSS
is incredibly powerful as we saw
yesterday at CSS conf and you get a
consistent accessibility treat because
you're accessing the browser's
accessibility tree so that's always a
winner as well and also I really liked
this little gem in the web spec that
convinced me that maybe I wasn't the
only one that with this API hardware
with this API hardware manufacturers
will have the ability to build
cross-platform JavaScript SDKs for their
devices doesn't that sound fun
like you buy a device and you're like
yeah don't load the SDK and just start
fussing with it in the browser I think
that would be really cool if they
started shipping that cool so how do you
use web --usb how much time we got we're
good all right so you've got your user
you've got your browser you've got your
device they plug the device in they are
invited to go to that website so let's
say that they're already there they
click something like connect or you know
start or something like that and that
user event clicks going to go to the
browser and from there we can actually
access the USB API so the browser will
then actually look for devices and you
can give it a filter so that you're only
really looking for one particular device
once it's found a list of device matches
based on your filter it will return that
to the browser and then the browser will
then pop up that modal that we saw
asking the user for that additional
permission to actually get started once
that user confirms that permission then
we can actually start getting the ball
rolling so that's why we can open the
device connection formally we can select
the right configuration that we want we
can claim the interface and then once
we've claimed the interface we have the
in endpoint and the out endpoint and we
can just start reading and writing which
is really really fun so this is all well
and good this is a nice abstraction but
what is this look like in code so this
is as short as it as it can get to get
started you supply some options when
you're actually requesting some devices
so here I'm just giving a filter and I'm
giving a vendor ID so most products that
you buy off the shelf have a prod
ID and a vendor ID and so the vendor ID
is obviously unique to the person you're
the company you're buying the device
from and the product ID is like for that
specific product itself so you can
filter on both vendor ID and Product ID
and you can be really really specific
about what device you want so that they
don't accidentally pick the wrong one so
that's pretty cool
so once you've actually supplied that
filter you can just call navigator dot
USB dot request device you put in the
options so that it knows which ones to
look for and if that comes back without
any errors I know that I'm not catching
my errors I'm sorry you can console.log
basically you can get the device product
name and the device manufacturer name
immediately so when you first plug in a
device you can read descriptors and
stuff and you don't necessarily have to
be like have an open connection to it
yet so you can actually glean a lot of
information about a device even before
you start opening it so this is kind of
the hello world of Web USB as you can
see it's not a lot of lines to get
started you do have to wrap this request
device in like a user event so you would
probably wrap that in a you know button
dot add event list and a click or
something like that it gets a little
more complicated and this is sort of
where sometimes you need to be familiar
with the device that you're interacting
with but you know we went back up to the
top so we requested the device that is a
promise that resolves once the person
has actually like given the permission
for the device after that we can open it
up because we have permission we select
a configuration I don't really have a
little bit too much time to go into
these things because they tend to be
more the actual USB spec itself not
necessarily web USB but if a device has
several configurations you choose the
one that's right for you and it's just
offering different end points and things
like that and then you claim the
interface which means that you want to
take priority control over the device
itself so if any other process on your
computer tries to interact with it it's
going to get locked out so it's really
just saying like this USB device is mine
and then you claim the interface that
you actually want so sometimes there can
be several interfaces that a device
office as well so definitely check your
datasheet and I'll show you an example
of what that looks like because don't
just guess the numbers like I was a few
days ago because as as my friend saw it
was not
good experience so I actually dragged
out the datasheet then after that once
you claimed the interface you can
actually start transferring things out
and you can wait for responses to come
back in so the first argument of
transfer out is the endpoint you're
transferring out to you and then the the
1a hex is just like the byte that I'm
sending and then if we want to receive
data we just say transfer in we give at
the endpoint that we want to read from
so that's number two in this particular
case and then we want five bytes so it's
not there's not a lot of stuff you just
have to know where those interfaces are
really and again your datasheet will
tell you that and then you can just
console.log out your response so that's
pretty good if you already know the
language that this device speaks then
you're off to the races so this is sort
of what a datasheet this is a screen
grab of Dasia I freaking loved attitudes
so much they like one of my favorite
things so this actually the stage she
comes from this programmer I have up
here that I'm going to demo later but
you can see all these descriptors and
stuff I just looked up those details in
the tables and I was then able to from
there pick the right interface pick the
right configuration it gave me the
literally the number of the end points
and everything so it's all pretty human
readable as well the bottom in the table
the bottom property there says num
configurations it literally says how
many configurations there are so you
know in this case if there's only one
then you're just claiming the
configuration zero right because that's
that's the only one and we're all index
0 so that kind of stuff can be really
illuminating just get comfortable
reading data see it I promise they're
not as scary as they look at first yeah
so I haven't really done a lot of HA by
demos for a little while but web USB got
me excited enough that yeah I'm back and
we're gonna do some really fun stuff so
that means some demos just to show you
like the power of web USB to get you
excited because this was oh very dry
like very speck so we've driven slides
but I have to give you a disclaimer
first so Web USB this is kind of like
snug UGG yesterday he was having to say
this about Houdini web USB is not super
stable right now so stuff keeps around
let me breaking it worked before the
lunch break
can't give you any guarantees it'll work
now everything I've made with you up web
USB is definitely duct tape City at the
moment I have duct tape on stage here
it's not quite duct tape but there is
tape holding my webcam up the second
demo I actually wrote on the plane
offline so just bear with me but I think
it's going to be really fun so let's
have a look at some demos so I'm gonna
bring up my camera so can everybody see
that screen right there
cool all right so I'm gonna plug the
first device in so the first device is
what you're actually looking at it is a
an Adafruit feather 32 u4 and it's just
you can pretty much swap this out for a
regular Arduino with a 13 for you 32 you
for chip and I've plugged in what's
called an OLED screen of which I've
written drivers for so I cheated and I
used some drivers or originally written
so I'm gonna plug this in and we'll see
if anything actually happens as its
supposed to
this is always the nervous part okay
cool
yes okay so see that popped up there
it's kind of hard for me to zoom right
now because I have a lot of stuff going
on my screen but it says feather 32 you
four detected go to web USB dot fragile
systems to connect so I'm gonna click
that alright it loaded thank you so now
gog he helped me ride a rainbow gradient
as the background for my demo this
morning over breakfast I'm very thankful
to him so I think everyone can see that
so I'm not going to do it anymore but
this is a virtual copy of my screen on
the webpage and then we have the real
screen here so we can have a lot of fun
so we can actually like draw stuff right
which is pretty cool but I have some
pitches that are readily mage like kind
of like turkey pie this morning thanks
that was really awesome this morning
this talk okay so what can we pick let's
do a cat cats are cool okay so that's a
pretty neat cat and let's see if we can
actually send it to this screen you can
tell I'm getting really nervous okay so
we connected you just saw this kind of
wipe thing happen that's just the screen
booting up as I connect to the device so
that seems to be pretty good so if we
click send image hopefully we'll see
okay so you may see
reverse cat come up because oh no no no
wait no we fix that okay that's fine
yeah
[Applause]
all right what else have we got I took
Tim's picture from the speaker page
sorry Tim so there's like a divot
version of damned Tim so I'm using like
the the Floyd Steinberg algorithm to
kind of dither it but you can use like
the game boy algorithm to I call it a
game boy algorithm what else have we got
we got Jays Kampf yeah let's send this
one yeah okay all right and I got one
more food this is a very special one for
all of you out there who have been on
Twitter recently yeah we should have a
radar smear
awesome cool so as you can see it's
pretty quick we are doing a little bit
of fun dangling with like fake serial
slash web USB and things like that I'm
gonna cover the tools that I use to make
this later on but that's kind of an idea
of how much fun you can you can have
with this kind of thing and by the way
the actual this actual interface here
where you can draw and stuff which I'll
just prove to you is actually working
yeah so that was actually made by my
friend Rachel while potty time excellent
on Twitter she created this really cool
thing called OLED Jas designer and I've
just been like hacking it into
everything I couldn't find right now so
yeah so that's awesome thank you so much
alright so that was the first demo
that's pretty cool but I sort of thought
I could do something really dumb and I
thought I could do this thing where so I
have an Arduino here right and it's just
an Arduino you know I'm sorry for those
of the back who can't see and I have
this AVR isp mark ii programmer plugged
into it so this is kind of how you can
use web USB to to flash an Arduino even
though it doesn't even though you would
normally need a serial interface for it
so this is kind of me cheating and using
a web USB device to flash an Arduino so
I didn't quite get it working but I kind
of want to show you like how cool the
interfaces you can make for this kind of
stuff so this one doesn't pop up with
like a website or anything whoa I'm
losing my phone okay so this one doesn't
actually pop up with a cool notification
but I'll take you to the local website
where I have it because I only have a
couple of minutes left okay
so hopefully this is still running
is I got inspired because I found the
very first website I made recently on a
floppy disk and it made me so happy so I
just sort of do something nostalgic for
this demo so and that website was like
eighteen years old it was it was
unbearably dorky okay so I'm gonna
connect to this AVR USP mark - and
luckily four years ago I wrote a
JavaScript driver for it so I've sort of
been trying to webpack everything now
and this just doesn't work very well
when you're on a plane with no Wi-Fi all
right so I'm gonna connect it oh it's
doing it okay so what it did was I
grabbed the program is signature
AVR is pima to it then asked for what
microchip signature I have on the
Arduino and then it showed me my fuses
and as you saw there was actually
flashing a program straight to it so
every time a I'll do it one more time
every time a page of memory so I think
for this tip it's like 128 bytes every
time 128 bytes is successfully written
it does a little thing on the progress
so just show you that one more time
because I'm really I think it looks
really hackery
but this is the kind of interfaces you
can make for hardware now it's so much
cooler than what you've probably seen
out there alright cool so so it's
writing pages writing pages this is just
like using a regular a custom event
emitter which is pretty chill and then
it's done so that's pretty cool so the
the catch with this is my array buffers
are showing really weird bytes right now
so the device doesn't actually boot
because I think it's writing stuff to
slightly wrong page addresses but I'm
still figuring it out but I thought I
would show you the progress of that and
how much you could depart from normal
headway interfaces cool so that's pretty
sweet
so the first demo was made with
basically a kitchen sink of items I used
Webb USB serial from my friend Lewis he
sort of created a shim and then you can
upload a nice script on the Arduino to
kind of act like that sort of it is a
shim on the Arduino and there's also
ischium with JavaScript so I [ __ ] his
project and just kind of had to like
refactor it slightly to work from Ryan
I'm using johnny-five to talk to the
oled junior screen and that's because
the OLED j/s library that I wrote
she just uses a johnny-five instance in
order to connect to that screen I'm
using PNG to LCD which has a library of
mind that does the Floyd Steinberg
algorithm thing to combine to do images
I'm using OLED Jas designer as I talked
about my friend excellent Rachel well
that was for my first demo and lots and
lots and lots and lots of web packing
yeah but I'm sure we're all used to
doing that by now
demo number two was made with AVR girl
SDK 500 vision 2 and AVL girl is P Mach
2
I apologize they just communication
protocols I just went to the spec and
implemented them so this is the kind of
stuff you can do now in the browser and
then I use webpack and I just wrote
really really really really bad code to
get that going but it seems to be
promising so far so hopefully I'll have
that working and I'll be able to blog
about that soon so future's current
support not great not great and I I will
admit of being guilty of swinging by the
Redmond campus I actually live in New
York that I'll go by the Microsoft
Redmond campus and I've literally gone
peddling USB web USB devices and I've
said hey can you give this to this
person on the edge team and this person
on the edge team so I'm trying I'm doing
my part at Microsoft but right now it
actually amazingly works on Chrome for
Android which is cool but it's really
just for Chrome right now so I'm hoping
that more browsers pick it up soon but
that is 56% of people globally so I
support this then well I really like
again the way Bo speaks back said this
will be good for the web because instead
of waiting for a new kind of device to
be popular enough for browsers to
provide a specific API for we can just
build it from day one which is pretty
sweet so if you wanted to get started
with an Arduino and web your suite which
is probably the easiest way even though
it's definitely the most hacky way have
a look at both the spec this Arduino
example which is a pretty easy to
remember URL and if you wanted to check
out my first demo I've pushed the code
to that address
so hopefully this got you excited about
web USB I'm very excited so I hope I
hope to see more open-source samples of
people playing with this kind of stuff
thanks
you
you